now in this circle what I'd like you to
do is I'd like you to pick any four
points on the circumference any four
points that you'd like I'll try to make
sure when you place them you don't make
you don't accidentally make some really
special shape like a square or a
rectangle so any four points so say here
and here maybe here and good morning Jo
sir yeah do okay so you selected four
points we're going to join them up and
create a quadrilateral all right now as
usual we'll name this fellow here so
let's call it ABCD yeah yeah I thought
I'd blow your mind well we can't do
anything anymore I don't know how to
work with these things it's all
different okay so this is a
quadrilateral now it's not a square it's
not a rectangle is not a parallelogram
at least I haven't intended it to be
it's any old quadrilateral except for
one fact which is that you can see all
of its vertices are on a circumference
of a circle and we have a special word
for this when you have objects that are
all on a circle and we actually have two
words for this think about this when
you've got three straight lines that all
go through one point we have a name for
this when you've got three points and
they're all online we one line we have
another name for that as well is in
order to remember if you've got three
straight lines they all go through
Center Point what do we call that I
heard something any suggestions yeah
okay very good so this one is concurrent
con current okay this one in here
they're on a straight line right so
therefore let's take a stab in the dark
collinear very good
there's one I forgot to put on here
which is it if you got parallel lines
like so right you've got an angle in
here an angle in here and they are
together within the parallel line so do
we call these guys very good
so you're say to get the thieve here
whenever you have objects that are
together in some way United in some way
we always prefix it with this code
prefix I'm just like cooperate or
something like that so because these are
all together on a circle right because
they are together on a circle we call
these guys corn cyclic okay con cyclic
together on a circle the points are a b
c and d con cyclic so therefore the
quadrilateral ABCD ABCD is a because
it's on a circle a cyclic quadrilateral
it's not just any quadrilateral it's a
cyclic quadrilateral okay
okay now what I'd like you to now think
about with me is if we define one of
these angles that's called this guy over
here for instance let's call this guy
theta okay if this is Theta if ABC is
Theta what I'd like you to do is you'll
need to get your your circle geometry
hat back on and think about the things
that we used last week can you find the
value of angle a D see if ABC is known
if theta is like 30 or 45 or 51 I say
like that if theta is known ABC what's a
DC that's the question mark okay so I'm
gonna give you a moment to have a think
about this how could you work out the
size of that angle in relation to theta
have a play perhaps make some
constructions and if you've got idea
call me over and we'll have a look so
when we're thinking about constructors
within a circle it's always useful to
think about radii cuz every time you get
radii you have equal angles and
isosceles triangles and all that kind of
thing but I can't even draw radii at the
moment because there's something missing
before that what do I need to draw a
radii I need the center okay so let's
try everyone should have the center on
their circle so I'm gonna put that guy
how's that look is that okay okay good
now then the question becomes well which
radii do I add because you could add a
lot of different radii here right now
yes now you can if you want if you want
you can't just add all the radii okay
you can put them all on however as we've
demonstrated in questions in the past
and in the question I'm going to do with
you immediately after we do this
property it's just as much of a danger
in a in a geometry question especially a
circle geometry question that you just
add on too much information right and
then when there's too much on there you
can't what we call is we say there's
like signal and there's noise right all
of it's just like this this is lines
everywhere clearly if I just drew lines
and joined up everything it would just
become a disaster you'd be looking for a
needle in a haystack okay
so therefore I want to draw my radii a
little more carefully
in order to get to my relationship
between these two angles okay
so what I'm gonna suggest is that if
this is oh yes given if we call that
center oh I'm going to suggest and I'm
going to ask you in every know why this
might be a reasonable idea I'm going to
choose to join a oh and see earth like
that okay now I could have joined OB and
OD that'd be fine
but can anyone suggest to me why it may
be joining up say OB for instance is not
a great idea it's not particularly
helpful yeah what do you think Oh
correct if I if I join this up right
theater gets broken up now it would
actually be really nice if you've got
broken up into half and one of them was
feet on to the other one was thing on to
but in fact I don't know that right you
get two very quite different triangles
here and here so the relationship
between the two parts of that angle it's
like I don't know right so you break up
something known into something arbitrary
and random and you're like I can't work
with that very much not that you can't
ever work with it but it's just harder
to deal with now when you have a look at
this I want you to think back I know it
was a whole week ago
have a look there are some properties
here I can take advantage of aren't
there right it ought to suggest once who
me yeah go ahead which where's sex
rights is Theta
you said yep this one over here see Oh a
a ha so you recognize that this angle
here is the angle at the circumference
standing on arc CB a like that or ABC
it's a better way there okay it's
standing on this arc over here the angle
you just mention a OB or marketing now
is going to be double that angle because
it's the angle at the center standing on
the same arc do you agree so I probably
shouldn't put a question mark let's give
it a better name to see let's call this
guy over here alpha okay so if that's
double and that makes that 2 alpha okay
that's progress